to help me i need help
listen if there are any chess.com
viewers send help
[Music]
all right well the uh the chat is ready
we've got myth in his normal streaming
setup where his fans have grown to know
and love him
dardoch is um sometimes he gets so
focused he goes full fobby full fabiano
where all we got is the forehead and the
hairline
i'd never go full fobby
is like i stopped my games and then he
started one
what is going on whoa he's starting
another game oh did he
start another game someone go aborts
okay good the staff reported
somebody shut down that man's ability to
start games
there we go i love how we keep aborted
now we started the myth game
okay there we go nice game on
i gotta get another game i gotta get
another game oh yeah
that was hilarious all right yep but
he plays the grub now that is
we'll see what he does with white now
he's uh starter's playing black here
myth is white
and an open sicilian day okay
i'd rather have it open sicilian than a
close sicilian i say
um i don't know where that came with me
and
no that was a very wise statement i'm
still you know i'm still considering its
implications and a night or
played by sardocian the night or is sort
of a big boy opening
it's just not something you waltz into
if you haven't studied openings
it's very theoretical you got to know a
lot of stuff and
uh e6 he's playing it professionally
so far right so maybe if i go knight
it'll like divert his attention here and
i have two takes here
for his two so he takes i take take take
or if he doesn't do anything around that
and he like plays around here
then i get his knight as well
let's do that let's see how that plays
out maybe that's not the right thing but
it does drop the piece of sardo's
reaction he takes that knight
like this he's he's still nervous
but i think he senses that the game is
turned around and now the clock
not myths friend either he's got now
down to a minute
unfortunately for white there's no
checks against black skin everything is
protected so
just down a piece now white's king is
the one on the shopping block
yeah i see chad saying and agree he's
definitely better than 4.95 the moment
some of these things start coming
together
myth is going to make i think bigger
leaps than than people will
expect because he's doing so many things
right but
um he's kind of almost too defensive
minded in some ways
yeah i mean he you know it's easy for us
to say you gotta trust yourself
everybody does that to a degree but um
he really as you said danny you really
does zero in on the right things
almost immediately and that is just not
something that
anyone takes for granted that's that's
some talent right there super tough but
anyway there are some maybe outside
chances there's only a minute for sarah
josh too so this is oh
he did take he took with the bishop if
myth gives check and he moves the king
instead of blocking with the bishop
we could have a wild ending like i just
predicted
yeah if myth sees that lobster pincer
theme
and i think myth is going to give the
check on c8 that's really the only thing
he can do here
unfortunately i'm worried that he's just
panicking and the
chance is vanishingly small but
nonetheless are dosh
stepping up in the critical moment here
got to give him some credit and b4 by
myth that's a really interesting movie
he's distracting the queen
from its defense of the bishop oh my
gosh this
okay just to show real quick before we
listen in if the queen takes and this
check happens
now there's no bishop d8 black would
still be winning but now you have to see
this retreating move
otherwise g6 and you get mated on f8 so
let's listen into myth and see what
happens here but this this could still
be a wild finish
below a minute now actually
good so this
gives me what this gives me free
the discover check is gonna be
devastating
okay yeah things
aren't as bad as they used to be oh
maybe i lied
[Laughter]
yep what am i oh wow this track
c5
i don't see five right oh we don't block
a pawn
move to a white checkmate there's still
that one checkmate okay
wait my queen is sucks
oh it all goes downhill dude it goes
south so fast
oh no
[Music]
good game my guy
what an intense game danny that was
crazy
good guess what they got another one if
that was tough classy and defeat
yeah this this this was actually the
play
and then he goes here i go here
mate and one oh because i go here
oh yeah he does like this or so he does
whatever he does here i win oh dude yeah
i didn't see that
that's like a that's like a checkmate in
three
yeah we could have won damn
well the more you know how impressive
myth was there we saw him at the break
taking time to actually look at that
mate pattern that i showed right with
the f6 queen f8 so he's really putting
in the time after his games to learn and
get better
and now he's got a grub to deal with
a grub named after henry grubb and
uh sometimes danny i feel like the name
of the opening sort of
implies whether it's good or bad and uh
let me just say that the grub is not
on an objective level a good opening um
and henry graub is not a bad player
grub also means like a coffin in in
russian so it kind of represents the
kind of opening this is
but he's already in a good position
because
myth's last move was not very accurate
okay well he's going to get two pawns
this way listen man if i'm losing
a d4 now knight e3 is
actually a really cool move 93 is
actually a super strong move and
black would be winning if i'm losing i'm
getting two pawns out of it
that's a really hard he might take on f2
you understand me
if i'm losing i'm getting two
pawns out of that bad boy
oh no oh checking he wants to check
oh he goes for a check yeah but now c3
that puts another piece on fire
oh my lands oh no
we're willing no oh
i'm blind damn it the grub strikes again
i'm coming after you kevin
oh this game has gone down the drain
fast
abort [__] gotta just
abort [__] boys it's not that you know
sardosa doesn't make mistakes it's all
about the consistency though
he doesn't blunder too much and even if
he's not playing great
he's not going to shoot himself in the
foot too many times
yep make this is playing quickly
uh or he's trying to speed up now
because he's down down to four minutes
um instantly broke back to c8 now the
grab pawn
is moved to unleash yet another
discovered attack apparently we're doing
basic tactical themes here today
unleashing an attack behind it
yep there it goes 10 moves after i
thought it would be played but
he doesn't i'm afraid myth might take
that pawn see that's another thing
where you tunnel vision the thing that's
hanging but
that's what where i've been impressed by
myth and
of course i have to jinx him as always
yeah but he is his logic is impressive
that doesn't take anything away from him
yep oh man
help me i need help listen if there are
any chess.com viewers
send help send help i'm
down bad i don't know if they have my
audio on but look at my lips
i'm down horrendous i am down
bad send backup send the cia
send the fbi send it to men in black
i don't send somebody
oh no oh
death is beth is among us boys
the ship is sinking all
has failed us this game things aren't
looking too hot
all right woman woman and uh woman and
children first
get in the light get in the wraps
get in the wraps take refuge
yeah this is a fitting a fitting uh
way of describing the situation oh
[Music]
no
not over nice yeah i think sardo's
enough pieces here
that was fun so
you know this was close until the very
end and uh andres you played very well
in the final
stage of the game to sort of make sure
that your king was safe but
it was intense as well we had no we had
no time actually we were both at two
minutes or one and
it was so stressful to actually find a
good move and
not blunder in this situation like wow
damn at that point in the game i
remember even like at this very phase i
was looking at the time and i was like
oh man 30 seconds left i just gotta move
something
and i don't have time to like i don't
think i was
um i don't think i was like good enough
i literally told myself like i'm not
good enough
to come up or think about the right
thing at the right time i just need to
move so i don't
just lose off
he told me just move the pc then it will
go well so
well speaking of your coach sardosh
before we move on from that
obviously uh mr blitzstream himself
kevin bourdee gets credit for the grub
this is uh it it worked out here
obviously man crazy
you just play against magnus and himself
with maybe
600 you know under him and he actually
beat him with the grub so
i guess if it's good enough for magnus
it's good enough for myth so maybe
you're in good company with the world
champion the grub is that the grub is
hard to handle
um but you know seriously man i know you
said yourself
chalk it up to inexperience but but i
mean that in a good way that
there were a lot of things we listened
in on you a lot and there were a lot of
times your thought process was like
totally on point and i just want to say
that because there were there were
moments where
and that game came down to the wire
where we were we were singing your
praises
and i know that you know where this
event is heading i just uh every every
time we we watch you stream here and
play chess it's
you're just getting better every time
man so just want to say that thank you
listen paul champs four and our next
match i have a few days
so i'm gonna i'm gonna you know nose to
the grindstone and hopefully you know i
could pull off a few dubs against nico
but then you know it from here and until
then i like chess as a game i really
want to stick to it and uh maybe maybe
i'll see you guys next year you know
yeah but it's a it's a lot absolutely
the way you're doing right now for sure
great games guys thank you
you